suit up it might get weird I'll be there
ASAP will we ever get to see frozen's
wife why is the reality there she is the
real MVP of this moon you care what she
looks like what you wanted to look like
what do you picture what do you think
she probably looks like cardi B now same
as minis it gotta be so are we going to
talk about it what the elephant in the
room
what elephant moms new job it really is
such a good movie easily one of my
favorites from Pixar I left and I was
like wow well I'm only I'm so over the
moon with this movie I'm so thrilled and
we thought we'd both fought last night
for the first time and I don't know it's
just it's I mean it captures so much so
many things are there's so many stories
told in this movie and the family part
of it is there but it's even deeper and
richer and more fulfilling there's
empowerment that's shared in both sides
but primarily Elastigirl but then
there's this whole other arena of where
all these these people with superpowers
are coming in these villains and they're
changed and and it's like that you know
there's a lot of them and they're all
weird and they all come and then on top
of that there's this whole thing about
the screens flavor thing which is no
good
[Laughter]
[Music]
for an important man ouch why scream
flavor the perfect villain for this day
and age
well you you're more articulate about oh
well I I feel like people are transfixed
by their screens and and I think your
observation is an awesome one that the
real danger is not how much were
attracted to them it's at that
information we've all started to become
aware that the information coming out of
the Internet is kind of yeah it has no
control over it it could be anything I
mean it could be anyone's opinion it's
not necessarily fact and you it can be
hard to discern that and then people
make choices based on a lot of basically
gossip and so it's those screens and
what's coming out of them and how
involved we all are in that information
and and how we haven't yet figured out
how to balance it in our lives is a
little frightening yeah are you kidding
I can't tell her about this not what
she's doing here on work what does it
mean to you to be a part of a movie like
this it's just so exciting you know and
I was asking Brad Bird who's our writer
and director I said like are you a
little psychic did you know it was
coming because they started working on
this movie four years ago Wow and we're
really in this resurgence of this
women's movement and I think what's
important is that we're talking about
parody we're talking about equal
opportunity and these movies create that
you know the first film mr. incredible
goes off and does the job and gets to
shine and now alas the girls going off
and doing the job and getting to shine
and you're seeing him at home navigating
what it means to be a stay-at-home
parent and how much work that is and and
you see the toll it takes on him because
he had no idea what a hard job that was
and that's real life you know families
are navigating how to make it as a unit
and raise their kids and deal with kids
beginning to date and try to figure out
what their identities are and it's
it's really something that I think
everybody can relate to it means fire
robbing the whole concept of the
incredibles the thing that got me
excited originally when I first had the
idea was that the powers are not just
superpowers they come in on different
parts of your life men are always
expected to be strong so I made Bob
super strong mothers are pulled in ten
directions at once so I had her be able
to stretch like taffy and on and on you
know teenagers are insecure and
defensive so force field and
invisibility ten-year-olds or energy
balls and babies are unknown so they
could have no powers or they could have
all the powers in the universe we don't
know what they're going to be so they're
unrealized potential and that that's the
fact that he's sort of a Swiss Army
knife of powers talks about the
potential of babies yeah
[Music]
means it's torquey what message do you
think this movie sends to kids and
adults respectively family is important
that the fact that these people have
these powers is secondary to the fact
that they are a strong unit even without
those powers communication strength and
joy doesn't come from you know a
superpower it comes from within the
family unit you know it's crazy right
to help my family I gotta leave it to
fix the law I gotta break it cute
cartoon for kids can have that choice
thank you young man
you